So when you use your app and
it sends the hits to Analytics,
it might take a while for the data to
show up in the Analytics dashboard.
If, like me,
you need the instant gratification
of seeing the hits being sent.
You can check the logs
in Android Studio.
So you're going to need to
enable verbose locking.
Can do that in startTracking method in
your application sub-class, like this.
You get the GoogleAnalytics instance and
then you set the logger level,
and you set it to VERBOSE.
You're also going to need
to import the logger class.
So when you've made these
changes run the app again.
Make sure your phone's connected to
Android Studio, and run the app again.
Now, down here in the logcat window,
make sure you're showing the logcat
window, set the logging
level to Verbose.
Make sure you have No Filters and
search, for sending hit.
If you have anything there already,
go ahead and clear it all, so
that you can start with a clean slate.
This is what your logging
settings will look like.
Then grab your phone and use the app,
and you should see the logging
entries showing up here.
And each time you go to
a screen in your app,
you'll get more entries
showing up in the logcat.
So eventually you're going to
get a bunch of log entries for
each hit that gets sent.
So let's scroll down and
look at one of the hits.
So an is the application name.
In my case, What's for Dinner?
And cd is a screen name, so
I went to the Show Recipe screen.
And I think the cd is for
content description, but
here it is the screen name.
Ul is the language.
US English.
And t is the hit type,
which in this case is the screenview.
And the tid, this down here,
is the Analytics account ID.
This gets taken directly
from the config files.
So if you've got the count
ID wrong in the config file,
it's going to be sent wrong in the hit.
There's no actual verification done to
make sure that this is a correct value.
And down here, aid is the package name.
So seeing these log entries tells
us that hits are being sent.
Now we can go look for
the data in the Analytics Dashboard.